our friends from the good liars have
done it again uh davrum and jason from
the good liars were at the nra
conference over the weekend they asked a
guy in a confederate flagshirt is he for
slavery or is he against slavery and the
guy didn't want to comment now in my
world if you don't say i'm against
slavery
you might be in favor of it but i'll let
you guys be the judge of that these are
extremely good videos that the guys have
been doing this is jason interviewing
this guy
um guys wearing a black make america
great again hat and a keep flying
confederate flag shirt
the topic is well
that connects to slavery are you for or
against slavery and the guy pleads the
fifth on the easiest question in the
world take a look at this just keep it
flying
keep it fine
and why do you want to keep it flying
why do you want to why would anybody
want to erase our heritage
well some people would say that that
flag symbolizes uh racism it symbolizes
slavery
um and they might have some valid points
there
that's their opinion you know they're
welcomed their opinion if they want it
are you are you pro-slavery or against
slavery
i have no comment
[Laughter]
no comment guys he is not going to weigh
in on that uh controversial
venomous political issue
thank you for the interview
i'll give you one more chance
pro bro or anti-slavery
uh no comment
[Music]
i what i'll give you does he know you
can be against slavery and still like
guns i mean
i don't know it's it's a very um
it's i i would not want to leave any
doubt my position on slavery one more
opportunity to say if you're pro or
anti-slavery no
no comment
all right well there you have it no
comment on the uh if you're in favor of
slavery or not
it is uh you know
it's a real gotcha question are you for
or against slavery now
let's be very
honest with ourselves and each other
we shouldn't be shocked that some of the
people with the confederate flag gear
are pro-slavery that's what the
confederacy was fighting to preserve at
the end of the day you know i i know
that it's it's so common it's almost
cliche that when you say to someone who
loves the confederate flag paraphernalia
you say
this stands for slavery this stands for
racism and so on they go no no no no i'm
against all those things for me it
stands for
heritage or you know whatever the case
may be and maybe for some of them that's
plausibly true
but at a certain point
the people that are still using the
confederate paraphernalia
some of them are going to be for slavery
and it seems like uh the guys that the
good liars may have found
such such a guy
um really disturbing stuff and again
we've talked about this overlap you know
the nra claims to be a non-partisan
organization they're just about gun
rights it's overwhelmingly republicans
it's overwhelmingly wrapped up with
christianity it's overwhelmingly
wrapped up with conspiratorial trumpism
and we saw literally the christian
pastor that trump brought up on the
stage during his nra speech who said i
believe you're still the president
you're you're still my president
uh
extremist right-wing christian pastor
nra members so we've gotta admit and
understand that that overlap uh exists
and how we deal with it i don't know
one of our sponsors is little spoon your
one stop shop for easy healthy meals and
snacks for your baby toddler or big kid
if you're a parent of any age child
little spoon makes healthy meal times
simpler and it saves you hours at a very
reasonable price little spoon makes
everything fresh just like homemade but
it's delivered to your door and ready in
seconds pop it in the fridge or freezer
and it is ready when you are they have
100 organic cold pressed baby food for
every eating stage awesome food for
toddlers and for kids they even just
launched a new line of on-the-go
smoothies that kids love everything is
nutritionally balanced no junk food but
it is kid approved it's food that
they'll actually eat and enjoy and you
can't beat the prices with kids meals
under five dollars baby food and
smoothie snacks under three dollars
little spoon is giving my audience 50
off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use the code pacman
the link is down below